نعم هنا قياده الخطوط الاماميه مركز
القياده اتحدث عليكم محراق واتلاف اي
بيانات وخرائط عسكريه والتتحضر للانسحاب
هذا امر عسكري علم وينفذ بهذه الطريقه
تلقت القوات الاوكرانيه امرا بالانسحاب
في هذه الاثناء قال يوري مديار قائد
اللواء الميكانيكي 28 بالجيش الاوكراني
قال ان وحدته الاستطلاعيه تلقت امرا
بالانسحاب من مدينه باخموت شرقي اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
فلتامر جهودك بالانسحاب ولكم ثمان واربعون
ساعه فقط
لن تفلتوا من العقاب والزلنسكي يطلب
المساعده العاجله من الغرب ليستجيب
الاوروبيون بارسال دعم مفاجئ وروسيا تساعد
احداث برياسك وتوجه اتهاما خطيرا
[موسيقى]
في المدارس الايرانيه والاوروبيون يصلون
فلسطين للرد على جيش الاحتلال ايعقل هذا
والامارات تفجر مفاجاه لمنظمه اوبك والنفط
ينخفض بينما تسيطر موسكو على جزيرتين
يابانيتين هي اليابان تعلن عن اكتشاف جزر
جديده
الانسحاب الاوكراني من بخموت شد وجذب وكر
وفر بين الاوكران والروس في مدينه بخموت
وبعد سبعه اشهر من القتال هو مؤسس مجموعه
فاقنر العسكريه الروسيه يعلن ان مدينه
بخموت باتت مطوقه بالكامل ولم يعد امام
القوات الاوكرانيه الا الانسحاب من طريق
واحد وفق قوله مع اعطاء مهله للانسحاب
بينما قال احد اعضاء المجموعه ان الجيش
الاوكراني بدا بتدمير منشات البنيه
التحتيه خاصه الطرق والجسور لعرقله تقدم
القوات الروسيه والهدف كسب مزيد من الوقت
كي تنسحب من ضخموت
ليعلنهار قائد اللواء الميكانيكي الثامن
والعشرين بالجيش الاوكراني بان وحدته
الاستطلاعيه تلقت امرا بالانسحاب من بخموت
مؤكدا انه سينفذ القرار رغم عدم معرفته
بالاسباب فعن اي اس
اولم تعلم بان المدينه قد حوصرت باكملها
ومن بخموت الاوكرانيه الى الروسيه حيث
توجهت روسيا اتهاما خطيرا وقالت الخارجيه
الروسيه في بيان الله من عمليات القتل في
منطقه
ارتكبت باسلحه النيتو وهذا يدعو للتساؤل
حول تواطئ دول الحلف واضاف البيان ان خطط
النيتو محكوم عليها بالفشل وفق وسائل
الاعلام الروسيه يخرج المتحدث باسم
الكرملين
لحمايه الحدود لترد روسيا ايضا وبطريقتها
الخاصه وذلك باعلان وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
اطلاق صاروخ كروس كاليبر على هدف ساحلي من
غواصه تابعه للاسطول الروسي في بحر
اليابان واضافت الوزاره ان الصاروخ اصاب
هدفه وتجاوز مداه
فما هو الهدف التالي امريكا ردت بدورها
وذلك باستضافه تدريبات بعسكريين اوكران في
قاعده تابعه لها بالمانيا وفق رويترز لكن
الرد الروسي لا يتوقف ومع مرور عام على
الحرب في اوكرانيا تلقى ما يقرب من الف
متطوع تدريبات عسكريه مكثفه في جامعه
القوات الخاصه الروسيه في الشيشان لننتقل
من حرب التدريبات الى معارك التهديد
والوعيد حيث قال وزير الخارجيه
ان بلاده لن تسمح للغرب بتفجير خطوط
انابيب الغاز مره اخرى واضاف ان موسكو لن
تعتمد على الغرب بعد الان كشريك في مجال
الطاقه مشيرا الى ان الغرب لم يتعامل
بجديه مع مخاوف روسيا ولم يحترم مصالحها
مؤكدا انه سيعاد توجيه سياسه الطاقه
الروسيه نح
[موسيقى]
من الاراضي الهنديه حين اعلن وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه ان واشنطن ستحرص على
ان تنال روسيا عقابها على الحرب
الاوكرانيه لان الافلات من العقاب سيشجع
دوله اخرى على انتهاك سياده جيرانها
واحتلالهم وفق تعبيره ليخرج متحدث البيت
الابيض جونكر بي قائلا ان الدعم الغربي
مستمر
لتكشف التقارير الامريكيه ان واشنطن ستمد
بحزمه مساعدات بقيمه 400 مليون دولار وهنا
جاءت دور على الرئيس الاوكراني
[موسيقى]
مستنجيدا بالغرب وقائلا فان القوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه تعاني من نقص في
المدفعيه والذخيره والطائرات العسكريه
والدبابات وطالبت دول الغربيه بتسريع
امداداتها الى اوكرانيا ليضيف ان اوكرانيا
بحاجه للمدفعيه لا لضرب الاراضي الروسيه
وانما للسيطره على المناطق التي استعادتها
روسيا مؤخرا وها هو يصرخ مجددا نحن بحاجه
لطائرات ليس بالاقاويل والوعود وانما
ببساطه بتسليمنا الطائرات وتدريب طيارينا
وذلك وفق وكاله تاز لتاتي النجده والامداد
من اوروبا وذلك باعلان الخدمه الصحفيه
للمفوضيه الاوروبيه اعتزاما الاتحاد
الاوروبي نقل خمسه الاف وسبعمائه
من انتاج شركه انل الايطاليه الى اوكرانيا
فيال خدمه الرد الاوروبي السريع على طلبات
اما في المانيا فطلبت برلين سويسرا ببيعها
بعضا من الست والتسعين الدبابه ليوبارتو
الموجوده في احتياطي الجيش السويسري ووعدت
بعدم ارسالها الى كييف حسب ما ذكرت صحيفه
وبين هذا وذاك وزير الخارجيه الصيني يعلن
رفض العقوبات الغربيه على روسيا معربا عن
دعم عمليه السلام لحل الازمه في اوكرانيا
وفق وكاله تاس الصين لا تهاب تحالفات
الخسوف مع كل يوم جديد تزداد الاجواء
قتامه اكثر وترتفع حده التوتر بين
الصينيين والامريكان وهنا مزيد من التوتر
والتصعيد في العلاقات الامريكيه الصينيه
مع تمديد بكين بالعقوبات التي فرضتها
امريكا على شركات صينيه وطالبت الصين
واشنطن بضروره التعامل بعدل والتخلي عن
سياسه القمع ياتي هذا بعد ان اعلنت وزاره
التجاره الامريكيه فرض قيود تصدير على 28
كيان صينيا بهدف التصدي لما تسميه تهديدات
المتزايده من الصين
الامن القومي الامريكي فهل يصمت اصحاب
العيون الضيقه اكثر لتزيد الولايات
المتحده من استفزازها للتنين الصيني
بتعزيز نفوذها في اسيا حيث استانفت في
تايلاند اكبر مناوره عسكريه بالعالم بعد
جائحه كورونا وبحضور 30 دوله مع مشاركه
كوريا الجنوبيه ليجتمع وزراء خارجيه دول
الحوار الامني الرباعي المعروف باسم كواد
وهي الولايات المتحده واليابان والهند
واستراليا موجهين رساله للصين انهم قلقون
جدا خيال الانتشار العسكري في بحر الصين
في مواقع متنازع عليها لكن اليابان عادت
لتطمئن الصين بان كواد ليست تعاونا عسكريا
بل مجرد تعاون عملي بانتظار الرد الصيني
يا ساده الاحداث والتطورات
موجه غضب عارمه اذ رحلت تسمم طالت مئات
الطالبات باكثر من 30 مدرسه في ايران
والرئيس الايراني يقول ان اعداء بلاده هم
من يقفون وراء هجمات التسميم لتطالب الامم
المتحده بفتح تحقيق شفاف في القضيه الدفاع
الامريكي برنامج ايران النووي تقدم بشكل
ملحوظ بعد انسحابنا من الاتفاق وفد اوروبي
يزور بلده حوار الفلسطينيه ويدعو لمحاسبه
مرتكبي الجرائم بحق الفلسطينيين وساقولها
للمره الثانيه انتم تكذبون كما تتنفسون
سجلت اسعار النفط العالمي انخفاضا حادا
بعد ورود انباء عن مسؤولين اماراتيين ان
الامارات تجري مناقشات داخليه حول امكانيه
الانسحاب من منظمه اوبك وفق بولست جورنال
الرجل السوري الذي سافر من المانيا الى
مكه المكرمه على دراجته فارق الحياه على
مشارف الحرم وبدلا من ان يصلي في المسجد
تمت الصلاه عليه هناك ودفن في مكه بعدما
اعادت اليابان احصاء عدد جزرها فوجئت بان
العدد الفعلي اعلى بكثير مما كان معتقدا
اذ وجدت هيئه معلومات الجغرافيه المكانيه
ان هناك سبعه الاف جزيره لم تكن محسوبه من
قبل بحسب سي ان ان هناك احد ينسى سبعه
الاف جزيره اين من يتحدثون عن ذكاء
اليابانيين وكوكب اليابان قوات موسكو اصرت
على اخذ بخموت بالقوه وبعد اشهر من
المعارك هي روسيا اليوم تخلق بخموت لتخر
سريعه فما هو التالي
[موسيقى]